bonjour à toutes et à tous et au delà
des mers ça va être difficile de vous
résumer en 15 minutes à peu près 40 ans
de quête de kate pour tâcher de casser
un peu les frontières entre les dix ans
différentes formes d'expression
plastique on va dire ça comme ça
et donc pour vous mettre dans le bain et
immédiatement
je vais vous présenter une film qui a
été réalisé en scope dolby stéréo cinéma
quasiment nos grands-parents maintenant
mais que j'ai numérisé pour les services
de la cause ensuite je vais vous
commenter les images au fur et à mesure
qu'elles passeront comme ça on arrivera
à accélérer les quarante ans en 15
minutes donc allons-y
ce travail s'est passé en 1986
avec l'aide des chercheurs d'ifremer
j'ai tenté de capter là où le vent la
marée la vitesse des courants et cela
pendant tout un cycle de lune
douze appareils improbable voyez là
commençait à se réveiller dès le
crépuscule et s'éteignait à l'aube à
chaque variation de mer et dans les
quatre éléments vous ai indiqué
précédemment
ces projecteurs qui était dans une coque
étanche avait tout un ensemble de
programmes qui variaient en fonction de
l'amplitude de la houle par exemple la
vitesse du vent
les transformer le bunker que nos amis
allemands nous avait laissés en espèce
de laboratoire une époque où seuls les
ordinateurs avait des petites lumières
vertes et des chiffres mais
l'information passait bien entre les
deux cerveaux et tout le public pouvait
venir évidemment constaté les phénomènes
à l'extérieur quand il ressortait qu'il
y avait cette vaste chorégraphie
lumineuse qui donnait une forme de
d'allégories visuel de la mer
vous allez voir tout au long de la
présentation de des espèces d'exercice
que j'ai tenté dans différents milieux
et différentes formes
l'intervention l'idée de cette quête
dont je vous parlais tout à l'heure
c'est que du crépuscule à l'aube on peut
être un spectateur d'une oeuvre d'art
sans être obligé de passer par un musée
ou de passer par les institutions qui
sont dédiés à l'art appelé aujourd'hui
contemporain on a quelques a toujours
été de pouvoir montrer ça au plus grand
nombre et à n'importe quel moment de la
nuit
comme vous pouvez le constater sont des
sortes de fiction finalement qui
disparaissent dès que le jour revient ce
qui va suivre
vous montrez un petit peu comment je
pratique ce mixage
de matière lumière je l'appelle
puisqu'ils n'y a pas tellement de
différence entre ce que je tente de
faire la démarche des sculpteurs
qui était bien avant la gemmi de la
lumière sous l'eau la nuit est ensuite
fait une transcription de cette lumière
dans une installation dans laquelle on
peut pénétrer
là il y avait un phare c'est pas
tellement de l'éclairer le phare qui
m'intéressait c'était d'obtenir les
reflets sur le clapot qui était en
dessous et j'ai inversé ce clapot pour
en faire une sorte de vertical allongée
tout en mouvement ça ce sont des gras
lui met d'opel s'il y en avait sur 1 km
de long sur un sillon côté du sillon du
talbert sion qui s'appelle aussi en noir
et qui est une formation géologique qui
rentre dans la mer voilà football parce
que vraiment quand on a installé sa il y
avait un temps calme et la tempête est
arrivée on a perdu toutes nos coeurs du
maître dans la nuit mais enfin on les a
retrouvés allongés le lendemain matin à
la marée basse on a donc fait une
installation ensuite à l'intérieur de
laquelle on pénétrait et à chaque fois
que je fais ces installations je capte
le son ambiant et il ya aussi un montage
manière pareil pour les alignements de
carnac qui se retrouvent sur un sorte de
grand mur sorte d'exosquelette lui aussi
projeter toutes les télévisions du monde
sur l'ancêtre de
de la captation satellite et donc toutes
les télévisions du monde en même temps
fut une espèce de grande purée pour en
finir par un éboulis de toutes les
chaînes de télévision du monde à la cave
comme un tas de charbon
et puis la nature particulière de cet
endroit qui est un immense chaos qui
étaient ensuite dans un gonflage blanc
respiration et en projection avec un
miroir au plafond donc avec une double
formation
et puis dans la ville des maisons qui
allait être détruite que j'ai échafaudé
exprès pour obtenir une une structure
lumineuse que j'ai ensuite retraduit
sous cette forme
tout ça est toujours en mouvement mais
je vais pas vous mettre des vidéos sinon
on aurait pour des hommes et puis ces
expérimentations me permettent de faire
des installations dans différents
endroits ça par exemple c'est un
collectionneur d'art qui avait un très
grand cactées de près de six mètres de
haut je suis donné la possibilité selon
ses réceptions de fait une sorte
d'hommage à barragan cet architecte
mexicain qui peut et c'est peut-être
et voilà il avait donc des programmes et
puis un autre encore le vent la matière
au quai branly dont on vous a parlé tout
à l'heure
là c'est un lac virtuel qui se trouve
être sous le sous le bâtiment de jean
nouvel qui a des variantes légère entre
la nature de l'eau les blancs sont
plutôt dominant quand il fait froid les
bleues
quand il pleut et les verts quand il ya
de l'évaporation
jeudi pour aller dans le très grand on
peut aussi aller dans le tout petit et
je me suis amusé à mettre en lumière des
fleurs afin de leur donner une espèce de
métamorphose improbable alors qu elle ne
bougeait pas mais c'est juste mécanique
de l'ordinateur qui a permis de faire ce
mixage et puis alors on passe dans un
espace urbain tout d'un coup là c'est le
port de marseille où il ya eu un très
grand programme d'aménagement mais
surtout de liberté de reprise de des
quais pour le grand public ce qui avant
il y avait des cabanes de plus en plus
importante sur le territoire public et
donc tout a été remis à l'eau si je puis
dire dans un très grand confort s'ils
ont aussi leur petit yacht club leur
grue tout ça sans avoir changé
aucune place pour les bateaux
donc ça c'est le mucem
cette peau de rudy ricciotti qui est
devenu une sorte de porte sardines
ça c'est central park
mais à ciney en fait c'est la réflexion
en quelque sorte pas en direct mais tout
ce qui a été enregistré dans la journée
sur les lumières de la baie de sydney se
retrouvent envoyé réfléchi sur cette
immense île héliostats qui est en fait
deux jours un grand miroir qui capte
l'eau de l'énergie et qui la nuit
restitue alors comment je travaille bien
voilà je prends d un ensemble de
matières que je devais ensuite travaillé
dans un certain nombre de tonalité
et c'est ça qui va se trouver être
projetés ça c'est un bâtiment historique
en quelque sorte c'est un magasin un
grand magasin à paris qui s'appelle les
galeries lafayette et donc j'ai fait
restaurer toute cette coupole et de lui
donner de la tonalité coloré en fonction
d'eux
des saisons parce que nous on a quatre
saisons mais ils en ont moins 12
donc à chaque fois qu'ils à la matrix
cette coupole chances de tonalité à
l'extérieur il y à tout un ensemble de
sorte de grande vaste chrysalide qui qui
change de tonalité en fonction de leurs
phénomène de saison ça c'est une tour
qui est au qatar qui est assez
extraordinaire pour capter la lumière et
donc la nuit elle devient une vaste
offensive qui change de de l'or à
l'argent
ça s'appelle la valeur des blancs un
petit gag mais bon disons nous pas trop
rien dit
sa petite soeur barcelone enfin je
dirais sa grande soeur c est arrivé
avant là c'est tout un phénomène
prismatique
le seul détenteur de berlin qui est
blanc prend toute sa journée mais qui
devient à des collations bleus en tous
les cas si on et magenta au moment où
les théâtres les restaurants s'ouvre à
la base alors que toute la journée ce
sont des des lieux de travail
ça c'est le théâtre de lyon c'est
toujours en fonctionnement je suis très
touché parce qu'il faut de la
maintenance quand même depuis le temps
savait pas plus de 20 ans et en fait il
ya des programmes différents et la
verrière au dessus change de rythme
selon qu'il y ait spectacle c'est à dire
tout le monde à l'intérieur en pleine
activité ou simplement répétition ou
alors simplement de pompier de service
là encore c'était de rentrer dans un
monde qui pas habituel pour moi c'était
de convaincre des ingénieurs que on
pouvait peut-être avoir un lieu
techniques si sophistiquées que
l'aéroport tout en ayant certaines
politiques est une expérience
intéressante puisqu'on a créé la 1re et
engouement de l'ensemble de la ville de
saint nazaire par le fait seulement de
mettre en lumière un certain nombre
d'objets portuaire ce qui crée un vaste
parcours géopolitique et ça a beaucoup
servi au maire ensuite et à toute son
équipe pour développer un très très
grand programme qui s'appelle ville port
et qui est toujours en route et qui a
dépassé largement cette petite
intervention évidemment c'était aussi un
espèce de manifestes sur le patrimoine
de la ville de saint nazaire avait été
rasée à 99% et donc c'était une ville
qu'il n'avait pas de patrimoine à
proprement parler tel qu'on l'entend
historique
en fait si vous avez surtout tout ça et
puis que vous connaissez sans doute pour
les bordelais ça c'est un indicateur de
marée en fait c'est pas l'air mais c'est
comme ça c'est plutôt vers qu'at-il fait
marée basse et c'est plutôt bleu quand
il fait marée haute et donc forcément ça
rappelle à bordeaux que la mer est pas
loin et qu'elle lui doit sa fortune
passer ça c'est la passerelle de la paix
séoul
et puis comme à force de travail et je
crée aussi des objets alors du coup j'ai
fait un 4/4 breton un peu cher parce que
c'est dans cette maison c'est toujours
affirmé c'est une lanterne qui se divise
en quatre parties on peut partir chacun
de son côté avec un morceau de la
lanterne
c'est un chargeur ça tient à 8 heures de
temps c'est un objet nomade qui va
dedans dehors
ça c'est la même chose avec pack arras
et s'appelle j'allume cc je souffle va
vous voyez toute plaisanterie qui fait
avec et ça c'est un hommage aux
souffleurs de verre donc c'est juste une
carafe et puis le banc le banc des
amoureux normalement quand on est deux
il est tout rouge puis bon quelques
projets rapide vite fait pour vous dire
que ça continue cette quête de vouloir
interpénétrés les différents métiers de
la ville en tâchant de donner un peu de
politique que se sortent un peu du monde
de l'ingénieur qui crée la lumière pour
voir et être vu pour finir ça c'est un
échafaudage qui me tient
particulièrement à coeur parce que en
fait il est en train de recouvrir une
colonne la colonne vendôme que
probablement à des unes des
commémorations les plus guerrière qui
puisse être puisqu'elle est entièrement
recouverte des faits
napoléonienne et donc pendant ce
temps-là est en train d'être restaurée
j'ai pensé que je pouvais mettre la
somme de toutes les couleurs de tous les
drapeaux du monde en douce respiration
puisqu'on n'est pas loin de la rue de la
paix c'est l'occasion quoi ça c'est un
dernière intervention très récente et
puis ça c'est ce qui va se passer à
denver dans le colorado
c'est une immersion dans un très très
grand dans l'aéroport
un très grand escalator qui est qui va
faire pénétrer les gens dans un dans
toutes les matières lumière que comprend
ce colorado aussi bien la glace des
montagnes que le désert l'évaporation
donc c'était voilà je vous remercie